y'all was gonna go how's it going my
name is Joker to Lulu aka The Fresh
Prince of YouTube I'm a bit crazy nuts
those are the same thing but I'll say it
twice and I'm a very nice guy all right
sighs ugh for many young Germans joka to
Lulu needs no introduction he's a star
on YouTube health reasons I finish
climbing I've always wanted to be famous
somehow since I was a boy but it's so
hard for me to wrap my head around the
fact that i really am famous now
submission 10 the council is Rufus vahab
he's known for his comedy sketches in
which he imitates Americans it comes
street comedy is his trademark hey
what's going on nothing you is your
beard fake know why are you laughing
stop laughing it's hard for people
Joker's age to imagine that there were
times in East Germany when you could not
say whatever you wanted because the
intelligence services were listening
then the mwange be fine better done if
the wall hadn't fallen Germany would be
a very sad country all the eggs onto
half the movie we can choose to live
wherever we like we can get a dresden or
anywhere else Wigan won't be forced up
into think there used to be this huge
wall in front of you it's just crazy
this wasn't cuff I never experienced
Germany split in two I just know unified
Germany that's how I grew up joko to
Lulu was born as Michelle vinta in
hamburg in 1989 his parents are from
Ghana time up this meeting is the idea
of home or a homeland is a tough one for
me when people ask me where I'm from I
give them a meter long reply and Ghana
finish I'm basically a foreigner in
Ghana even when I'm there I'm still the
German and that's funny because it's a
different world as I under the bait so
my homeland is where I grew up and
that's Germany with my deutsch done joka
said he was shy as a child but then at
school he started to tell jokes and got
a positive response from his classmates
he was also in a band after graduating
from high school joka joined the army
showing allegiance to Germany
a few months ago he moved from Hamburg
to cologne because it's become a center
for youtubers
good targets the whole homes where you
feel good but that could be with your
friends or wherever you have Wi-Fi
recent studies say fourteen to twenty
nine year olds in Germany spend more
time on the internet than watching TV
they spend about four hours a day online
more than double the German average they
look for information check their emails
hang on on social media sites and watch
videos for example on youtube Joker
Tallulah's youtube channel has more than
a hundred and eighty thousand
subscribers and he has a contract with a
large content production company lighter
go to see how it's a toggle
unfortunately nowadays you're defined by
likes and followers follow us on the
weather I think if you reach a lot of
people that comes with a certain
responsibility ultimately found photo
one of his most famous videos is a
racism Street test how racist is Germany
related well I got a very racist message
here and I'm gonna ask people if they
have the heart to translate it for me do
you speak a little bit English a little
bit like you wrote me a message on
german but i don't really like
understand it so could you like just um
translate for me it's not nice what do
you wrote
like you should meet him he's not nice
it's guy for the team I got this one I
like to take on the issue of racism not
necessarily because I've had so many
experiences with it myself but because I
know that there are people who've had to
deal with it a lot of home done with the
bathtub at the moment there aren't that
many darker-skinned youtubers who have
as big an audience as I do so I see
myself as a kind of spokesperson for
them like many of his generation Joker
sees himself not just as a German but
also as a citizen of the world when my
name is Joker to Lulu aka The Fresh
Prince of YouTube my nationality human
Mitch 25 years after german
reunification he says his generation
still faces major challenges H Bajrangi
Guatemala [ __ ] find a big wall fell
in half this small worlds in people's
hearts still exists the those are the
people who withdraw from other people
because of skin color because of
religion and so on those are the walls
that still need to be torn down you want
Thomas